chris derrick thank you so much that i'm
fascinated by that player
yeah the longevity there that kind of
cal ripken junior uh
type of lifestyle and example we're just
talking about that still playing right
on the ice with everybody else
unbelievable hey we talked about i tried
to fly that kite this weekend right yes
you were saying you actually uh
it was it was not exactly a successful
endeavor it's not easy
did you hear about that no i knew the
winds were going to be windy this
weekend so i told
harlow we're going to fly kite so we
bought one of those big pterodactyl ones
uh-oh
i was like okay i'm going against the
wind it was going great but those things
are not easy it turned around and
started coming at us and i
said run the pterodactyl
it's a meat eater
flag kites is not easy believe me let's
show the beach right live look outside
black mountain showing the las vegas
strip great sunset there good to see
that current temps outside
87 in centennial hills somewhere in 80
even 85 for aliante double eights in
downtown
sunrise manor 87 green valley henderson
you're currently at 87 as well
rhodes ranch southern highlands located
here here at 84
82 for seven hills outside of town 85
for prep
82 for sandy valley 86 boulder city 92
for loffler
southwest radar dry here some showers
look at this up there into a utah
but that's changing over to snow in the
mild high look at that
snow still continues in denver we'll
have several systems in the pipeline
that will dive down towards us
and as they do they're going to do this
we know we're going to get a roller
coaster ride in temperatures that's the
roller coaster right going up
and then going down again so look at
these numbers temperatures in the high
80s and then cooling off again
especially next week we'll also see some
wind along with that too
so breezy tomorrow and wednesday gustier
winds expected over the weekend into
monday with that cooldown we just
pinpointed out to you
so here's your most accurate eight day
forecast now breezy like we said on
wednesday
now you'll notice the temperatures like
we said we've been pointed out to you
will cool off
and then warm up but notice slight
shower chances for thursday and monday
i'm not really big on the prospects of
actually getting some rain on those days
it's just a slight
chance which is why i didn't change the
icon but we do know we're going to get
wind like we said on saturday and sunday
that's going to knock us back down to
the high
70s that's going to be below average
again for this time
of the year that's your most accurate
forecast don't forget to catch us at 11.
back over to you